talent mais qu'il a fait un vol plané
dans mon âge sujet sérieux mal et qu'on
y est c'est fait pour le buzz ce taux
est passé bien qu'on a un fils de [ __ ]
aux poules best of des esquives à sion
d'une betty attention saut de l'ange in
the world j'aime faire prendre mon colis
mec l'autre c'est même pas de l'eau en
fait c'est du sol poster pas de quoi tu
me parles
et ce qui arrive ça sûreté tu étais tu
meurs demain j'avais trop bu et un coût
a atteint coin 20 juin en un coin
par contre y'a un truc qui va pas le cas
c'est que on a pas du tout de besoin de
trop tu t'es fait gang bang la mecque
j'en ai marre gta très jolie d'abonnés
mais harry johns prolongement quoi bon
sens tu avais peur qu ont peur merde
à oued el fait qu'est-ce qui était basé
web desk amants n'ont fait dans des
poêles de portugais joy
il cherche sa route omar mon gars ça tu
pouvais mettre un pokémon à la place
c'est ça me fout moi ça serait trop bien
et j'imagine d'études fait point un
trait les capitaux des fois il a désigné
les excès de confiance est là bon ben
decca faut se prendre la tête on se
recroise homme un bordel faut aller là
c'est mon style sont d'apparence saine
on m'appelle le gard cette équipe et
c'est regarder le mur mon gars si je me
mets face au mur les n'y verra mon cul
en arrivant je suis trop drôle à bois
coupé en assure ben bella j'en ai eu
aucun loup 12,3 public c'est shit et là
y'a de la chip dans l'air y a du chic
comme le shit confirme
le blanc le blanc de la concentration
grave grave
ladies and gentlemen au joli en
exclusivité totale mondiale le cycle de
la vie de call of duty vous est présenté
par squeeze d'un jeu spawn je meurs je
spawn jeune mère m'a retiré de l'argent
la division ou la lazio
on n'a pas du tout les cristal en super
g c'est totalement faux
j'ai joué sans retour pour comme moi
j'ai des petits fous toi par contre ça
comme salma est simple parce que c'est
toujours toi los teques ta cote de mrdja
lesponne ma faute je suis américain âgé
je me fourchette qui on doit relier un
câble espagne à 3 kms pas une fourchette
ses taux il se croit dans assassin's
creed un peu les jambes j'ai un instant
mais la personne outre de bababé trop
tendres au concert ses moustaches je la
mets sur sa tête ça fera c'est
l'événement moi j'avais le jeu vrai
bateau qui tournait à oui le truc qui
volent et oui oui courbot on en parlait
tout à l'heure avec un pote
il disait que la larme quand elle sonne
une fois c'était qu'un vol deux fois un
feu et trois fois une cfa 2 juin ouais
voilà way j'étais mort j'ai fait mais tu
imagines dans les petites campagnes
genre je répète vol à l'épicerie du coin
je répète